we should read this story because this
is crazy look at this
elon musk mum on twitterverse please to
deactivate teslas in russia
who in their right mind look at this
space ceo elon musk has been mum on
requests from twitter users to shut down
tesla's in russia this as he provides
free internet access to ukraine and free
charging for all electric cars in nearby
countries here's an idea shut down all
tesla cars in russia with a note hi guys
you'll get your cars back when you stop
fighting ukraine one user tweeted
another said time to start time to shut
down russian teslas with a kill switch i
know you can do it so far musk hasn't
responded now the first thing i want to
say is well they do mention elon musk
says in reference to censorship he's
been told by some governments to block
russian news sources we will not do so
unless at gunpoint sorry to be a free
speech absolutist bravo good sir i also
want to point out look some twitter
users tweeting at elon musk does not a
story make exactly but
the sentiment among these pro-war people
is kind of nightmarish these are
torch-wielding pitchfork-wielding people
who are like screaming burn the witch
and they do it for everything like the
the video i like to bring up were the
guys chasing them around around the
store because she's not wearing a mask
and he's like is anybody else mad that
we all have to wear masks and she
doesn't like these people are the kind
of people who just want to grab
they're they're like waiting outside
saying oh gonna get a pitchfork let me
get a pitchfork i want to chase people
and scream
the idea that we're not going to war
resulting in them just saying escalate
the pressure and the tension and the
pain is a scary thought perhaps what
we're dealing with in this great culture
war or cold civil war is a kind of yin
yang and we are the people who are kind
of like
we should reduce suffering as much as
possible and they're the kind of people
who are like we should increase as much
as possible
yeah i actually um tweeted i was like
what is going to happen when people
can't afford to drive to work and i had
people responding to me saying they
deserve to suffer you know we should
raise the price of gas or like the price
of gas is much much higher in the uk
that's fine they should raise it higher
people need to buy electric vehicles and
i was like what are you talking about
you're just raising net suffering in the
world for what purpose it's because they
don't have a point of reference it
doesn't actually affect their life so
they're not going to care right and it's
crazy because i always used to talk
about cancer culture and why cancel
culture will ultimately lead to
stuff like this and people don't get it
it's literally just wanting to incite
more pain but what is that actually
going to do right make things worse
right yeah but they don't know that
or they do maybe they do they do yeah it
reminds me of a kid who's torturing ants
you know they just revel
they're just reveling in the suffering
of others it's really weird man
that is psychopathic to revel in the
suffering of others and to think that
other people deserve to suffer for not
following your particular ideology is
probably as close to evil as anything
that i can come up with i'll i'll i'll
give you guys something to ponder
so i was thinking about this um
several years ago i think when i was in
i might have been in ukraine or or
something i might have been in ukraine
yes like 2013 2014
and like why people are protesting and i
thought about how they say like the
economy is really bad and you know we
work for a month and what we average the
average income is like 400 a month or
something and they were like if we join
the eu the economy will be better and
everyone will have you know better
access to things and then i was like
what what would happen
if the cost of water was greater than
than than the cost of labor
if that ever happened you will get total
revolution instantly total revolution
so
we pay our water bills when you live in
a city right so detroit this is what
kind of got me thinking about it was the
detroit and the flint water stuff
it's the most expensive in the nation i
don't know if it still is but it was at
the time
and uh the reason was this was there was
an act there's an activist i know who's
based in detroit who was working on
fixing the pipes and all this was going
down and he said that it used to be
cheap to get water to your house but the
more people leave michigan
then the more the cost of the water
system is spread out among the remaining
populations
so if you have a million people and it
costs a million dollars a month that's a
one dollar per month if half a million
leave your costs just double the two
bucks a month if you know another you
know 250 000 leave now it's four bucks a
month it's actually substantially more
than that but because people are fleeing
michigan the cost of water was going up
and up and up to the point where i guess
what happened was flint switched off of
detroit water into like flint river
water which was nasty and then caused
corrosion or something but i digress the
point is i started thinking about this
and i'm like water costs money to get to
you food costs money if high food prices
result in civil war because people can't
work enough to eat then what happens if
they can't work enough to drink any
water it'll be worse than a revolution
because people will be trying to just
steal water like water the most valuable
thing on the planet for you know for
people well become such a double bind
when you can't afford the gas that it
costs to get to work like today uh or i
commute 20 miles each way and at first i
was worried because biden was talking
about putting a tax per mile but now i'm
just concerned about the price of gas
and how it's going to affect everything
long term it's only going to get higher
no over here it's going to hit four
dollars soon it was 350 earlier um this
week and i was like
thank god that i make ends meet but
normal people who are just scraping by
already
unsustainable and what do you do you
can't even uh earn the money to buy the
food you know what the craziest too the
craziest thing
you could do right now is shut off
electric vehicles
this was the stupidest thing these
people could have tweeted
because right now the refuge is in
electric vehicles you're concerned about
high gas prices they come out and they
say well buy electric if elon musk has
the ability to snap his fingers and turn
my car off and he does
that's kind of scary yeah
i suppose though with a lot of modern
vehicles they could do that to any car
if it's gas powered yeah so you know
what here's what i'm thinking i'm going
to buy a bunch of emergency food i'm
going to then buy a car from like early
1960s no like with no computer
components and anything like that an old
mustang or something oh yeah and just uh
get ready for that solar flare or
whatever we got to grow food i think uh
oh we are big time inside indoor food i
think indoor food growing is the future
and should be localized oh yeah every
human should have we're working with
these this company called eden grow
systems right now and they've got this
nasa technology where you can grow like
zucchini and strawberries inside uh four
of these standing things can support one
human indefinitely so we're gonna get a
200 gallon aquarium and we're gonna put
bantam chickens in it that they're like
little tiny ones and then we'll have
miniature eggs every day i'm just
kidding
i'm getting excited so no we are
actually getting a big aquarium for
raising babies in because we have actual
babies not human babies
because we have 54 eggs currently
incubating you know this they just keep
making more of them and you know we
decided to turn more into chickens just
let them you know do their chicken thing
the cost of gas going up is causing the
cost of food to go up because it costs
more to transport the food the diesel
i'm wondering if there's a way we can
make a kind of a
fuel for a vehicle out of egg
oh my gosh and then we can take all the
eggs we don't need i thought we could
cause you everything we want to eat
first you know what i mean we should you
want to try to use something that has no
other real application yeah the grass oh
we should look into the water car
stanley myers water car he had a he had
an engine in 1996 he patented this
engine that could take him he said in 22
hours 22 gallons of water he could get
from l.a to new york and then they
wanted to buy his patent they kept
offering money off of a billion dollars
he refused he had a lunch meeting one
day with a couple of investors and in
the middle of a lunch meeting they
poured him some crane rages he runs out
grabbing his throat and his brother
comes out and he's like they poisoned me
and he died i don't believe that look
this guy up stanley meyer it is freakish
who told that story i just it's on the
internet there's a video of him pouring
water into the gas tank and being like
showing he goes down the river and he
gets water out of the river pours it
into his tank and turns his
motorcycle yeah but this could so i
don't know much about this is the
electrolysis vehicle because that's not
that's that's a that's true it's just
the issue is it takes more energy to
perform the electrolysis to get the fuel
out of the
the what i was reading said that he was
getting a net positive energy because
the water was the additive energy no so
you need uh an electrical current to
separate the the the base elements of
the water to utilize the hydrogen right
so that the issue was the water car
works everyone knows it works but you
need a greater charge externally to
generate the fuel
to generate the electrolysis which
creates the fuel from the water so it's
not like you just pour water in a drive
you need a battery and it's just a kind
of combustion
well i'm going to look i'm going to look
more into this so i can bring a deeper
understanding of stanley meyer's water
car because if we can use water as fuel
that would be revolutionary i think that
it may be noble to think of these
revolutionary things man but i think you
got to obey the laws of thermodynamics
and we shouldn't get into wishful
thinking but the energy
the energy you put into it is you're
getting the energy you're putting into
is the water so it's not that you're
getting more energy out you already have
the input and i don't think you've read
enough about this what happens if
there's a drought you're right
uh that will exacerbate everything
that's happening on earth right now and
what what happens if people need to
drink water and everyone starts pouring
in their cars and there's a water
shortage and the price of water
skyrockets and that's fighting yeah i
think that's all going to happen
inevitably without it being a fuel i
think there's a lot of people who want
to believe in these magical solutions
they want to be like we don't need
fossil fuels we don't need to drill we
don't need this we can just power our
heating and food with good intentions
you know just put on a put on a special
headband and the whole machine just
turns on with the good intentions of but
one man no it just doesn't work that way
we need energy without energy people die
so when greta tuneburg comes out and
says how dare you to everybody and she
says we won't wait until 2030 or 20 not
even 2023 we want to shut down now it's
like she annoys me she doesn't know what
she's talking about yeah right i mean
that would kill millions of people but
okay that's an idea let's not do that
moving on and anybody else in the room
have any any thoughts because that was
insane well in it's fun it's ironic
because i think in the long run them
trying to push for these environmental
policies right now is going to be way
worse for the environment overall even
like if those
assuming those policies would actually
be effective because if there is one
thing we have seen historically and
worldwide it's that environmentalism is
a luxury and so if you [ __ ] our
economy to the point where it can't
bounce back we are not going to be
environmentalists we're going to be
doing everything that we can to try to
survive
yeah and so joe biden keeping pipelines
closed or trying to implement whatever
other you know energy
independence demolishing
pro-climate measure
is just going to make it more impossible
and more difficult for our country to
sustain itself and for our economy to
survive which means in the long run
there's going to be less potential to
actually develop the technologies that
would help improve the environmental
circumstances that they're claiming are
going to be to our detriment we're at
like a launching period right now where
you have to you're going we're creating
the momentum to bounce off the diving
board to dive into a future of
energy off of fossil fuels but in order
to get that momentum we need to use the
fossil fuels fusion
stuff like that i think that that's
being repressed personally because the
people in power are afraid that if an
individual had infinite electricity they
it's not they lose control it's not
infinite and it's not infinite you're
right no i slower
i think
the people who run the energy companies
desperately want fusion to work so they
can control it and own it and then
they're the barons of this massive
energy supply
so it's good for them
they make money
how
i don't think you can if i had like a
fusion generator in my house i really
don't want to derail this into me
dreaming about my fusion generator no
this is powerful companies that invest
in new forms of energy because if they
own that form of energy you're dependent
oh yeah they have the only fusion
generator but if everyone's got their
own
if they own the fusion generators in the
process
i mean look
you're you're not going to have a home
fusion generator that's that's that's
ridiculous that's what they want you to
do we have small generation fireplace in
your house we have small generators you
can power your house with but it's not
practical for the in the long term you
get you get a natural gas or diesel
generator for your house you turn it on
sometimes but you're not going to want
to keep constantly putting fuel in it or
whatever fusion's fantastic it's a lot
of energy but it's not permanent it's
not infinite energy comes from somewhere
so you'll you'll have a backup generator
for those who have it but the power
plant will just be a fusion power plant
you'll pay your electric bill and you'll
be dependent upon the system that's what
they want you might be able to get a
cold tabletop fusion generator and then
you just pour deuterium into it which is
uh heavy water water with an added
neutron and then um in a palladium
lattice and then you can bombard it with
electricity
that's called cold fusion i don't know
if it's science fiction and the issue is
there's not going to be some dude at his
house who's like let me just pour some
heavy water into this machine and ah now
i can power my house for a hundred years
well this is not in the ocean i think
it's like i don't know what percentage
it's a very small percentage of the
ocean water is heavy water it's in
nature so you might just be able to pour
water in and filter out the heavy water
right but but like you're talking about
a hundred years in the future i'm like
science fiction i'm grabbing at straws
because it is terrifying to think that
we're hung up on oil still and it's
going to be oil because oil works
because oil is profitable no yeah it
does work it's profitable because it
works because it's profitable because
they can control who has it no ian you
can't when there's no wind you've got no
wind power there's when there's no sun
you got no solar power well
there's a wind generators you have no
wind power either when there's when
there's no
yes the issue is
when it comes to wind and solar they
don't work sometimes
fossil fuels work 24 7 so long as we're
supplying the fossil fuels into the
machines and if it's not too cool that's
why it works nuclear power works yes
nuclear power is also reliable but for
some reason
the establishment doesn't want nuclear
power
i don't understand
they got to sell you that oil man
yeah yeah also i'll give you that one
you know we absolutely should be
building more nuclear power plants and
we're not yes
absolutely so they do want to sell us
that oil i suppose the fear is that
if we get off oil too quickly
china or some other country swoops in
and starts taking it plus there's oil
interest potential for war like what's
what's china russia or saudi arabia
going to do if we're all of a sudden
just like
oil no more no no more petrodollar i
think i think one of the reasons we're
so adamant on maintaining oil is not
just because it works it's got a high
energy return on energy invested but
it's also because the us uses it uses it
as a control mechanism i was thinking if
john rockefeller were alive today that
he would be really upset with what
people did with his oil this whole oil
world i don't think he intended for it
to become a weird sociopathic monopoly
he was you mean government control yeah
like he unleashed the beast of greed of
just of covetousness of this oil all
over earth i don't think that was his
intention i think the issue is you can't
ship nuclear power right you build a
nuclear power plant you put small
nuclear reactors in submarines and stuff
and they can power them
but if you want
to transport energy and sell it and
control the mechanism by which it sold
the petro dollar
oil is a substance that can be moved all
around the planet
you get everybody to buy and sell using
us currency the reserve currency and you
own everything that makes sense and it's
liquid too you can i don't want to give
it up pipelines and stuff that's right
and then you've got pipelines everywhere
and they don't want to give it up
but if we were to shift in the united
states to nuclear or other renewables
then we would lose the ability to point
the weapons at people and be like buy it
with our money or else
interesting so how much oil is in alaska
is there any way that we could be energy
independent by that well we were energy
independent technically under donald
trump we were a net exporter of what
right and then as soon as biden gets in
it's like start importing oil again and
it's funny because they're like biden
didn't do anything and i'm like he ended
oil and gas leases because of the
climate cost that was reported by the ap
right that's just i'm not even going to
say anything else joe biden shut down
oil and gas leases like a month ago yeah
he did he's like oh the cause the
climate cost is too high okay well you
know
you made a good point that climate that
like caring about the environment is a
luxury yeah it is
yeah it gets scary man i'm seeing i'm
seeing a discussion among the experts
that if russian imports are shut down
then gas could be over 200 crude could
be over 200 bucks a barrel and then
we're looking at 750 or eight dollars a
gallon
jeez yeah man yeah that's crazy we're
going to be on like horse and buggy
again i know i know
that's kind of cool though horses are
fun
that's fun no definitely like i don't
know i don't know i love my car but you
can hug a horse instead of mechanics you
have to go to a vet yeah
yeah yeah really good time and it's
funny because like when you're like in
the carriage and the horse is walking it
lifts its tail up and just poops right
all over the place and right no no but
here's like right on the ground like
when you get a fertilizer it's great
when you're getting an oil change you
got to go and you get this why can't i
just pour the oil down the sewer drain
you know
apparently you can't do it yeah you can
but if your horse takes a dump no
problem
yeah you put jingle bells on your horse
that's right
you're selling this idea that's when the
horse when it's dark at night and you
hear ding ding ding you know how fast
the horse is running and where how far
away from you it is that's why they put
bells on the horses what would road rage
look like with horses
what did road rage look like horses
people people with like a saber on the
right side or the guy riding a shotgun
with an actual shotgun yeah look i'm not
gonna say it didn't exist but also i
think part of the reason you have road
rage just because of the anonymity of
being behind the wheel if you're on
horses and you're like looking at the
other guy i think people are a little
bit less tough howdy neighbor we're
going slower yeah yeah you're going
slower yeah but people also had swords
and guns no that's true i'm not like i'm
sorry yeah like i'm saying people people
got into fights and they were angry but
i know what i mean it's a big part of
the reason why there's so much road no i
get what you're saying too that there's
a deterrent there somebody's actually
going to fire you you're yeah there's
the duel yeah that's crazy people people
in government used to duel yeah that was
literally a thing there's actually a
movie about the last duel did you guys
see that no it wasn't some french guy uh
alexander hamilton and aaron yeah and
apparently what did they say hamilton
didn't really expect to shoot aaron burr
he thought it was going to be a
gentlemanly honor thing and that they
would duel but he would intentionally
miss and they would move on but aaron
brown was like i'm gonna kill him so why
would john why would you assume that you
can't it's not a secret don't let
someone point a gun at you like it's
okay they won't shoot me bro like
i don't think those things were very
accurate and so they're kind of like
walk 10 paces turn around there's a bang
we go home but the guy got him got him
so you know
and then apparently the younger
generation was offended by it was like
people should stop dueling and i'm kind
of like i don't know some states still
have mutual combat i think oregon has
mutual combat right interesting let's
look that up i don't know how about we
do that for the next presidential
election yeah
i love this
like
the the children of joe biden and donald
trump are are entitled to enter a ring
and challenge each other only only the
presidential families you know we had a
uh tv host radio personality and donald
trump be president i wouldn't be
surprised if we have two fighters that
fight for the presidency in the next
hundred years i wouldn't be surprised
the way it's going yeah washington and
texas are the only two states that still
allow mutual combat so uh washington
yeah washington oregon this thing about
the last duels from 1386 it's a movie
that just came out last year uh in
medieval france john de carusje i don't
know how you pronounce that exactly
it was like the last legal duel i think
in europe i'm not 100 sure should
dueling be legal yeah would you say yes
yes
you were just ready with that one you're
like absolutely why
why uh because
judging by social media a lot of people
are
are already
ready and they pretend they're tougher
than they are so i would like to
actually do an experiment just for
science i think we solved all of our
problems yeah yeah to all the great
reset world economic forum people who
want to depopulate bring back dueling
perfect and for all those who don't like
cancel culture let the canceled culture
people duel each other it's win-win yeah
here's the thing just goes outside and
starts fighting our country is so
polarized that like for the first week
when people were talking about bringing
dueling back and be like yeah yeah let's
do it and then when it came time to do
it it would happen for like a week and
then people would be like all right like
i really don't want to do this no you'd
get you'd get the right being like guys
this is ridiculous we can't just start
fighting each other and killing each
other and the left would be like you're
a bigot dueling should be allowed as
tradition for various cultures and then
as soon as the right says okay fine we
agree let's start doing they'll be like
well we actually think dueling is wrong
we've evolved on the issue this would
never agree on it it's not allowed this
movie's about uh the last what's called
judiciary duel held in france and then
later 1547 was the last legal duel in
france i guess we're still doing in the
united states i'm just saying i think we
should have actual trial by combat like
at a court it's like you walk in and the
judge is like we have the case of you
know the state versus john smith you are
speeding you're going 30 and if you're
you're going 30 miles over to 45
i would like to fight the officer your
honor
the floor expands into an arena and the
cop is like you know you're like gotta
wrestle like takes his wig off and he's
like they're all going right now
cops would be very worried about like
they pull a guy over and he's like six
seven and super ripped and he's like you
have a good day sir yes
let them go if they did let the
presidents duel for combat for uh
experience would they have be able to
like claim like a champion like would
biden be able to bring a champion into
fight for him no wait he's too old to
fight
here's what we do
international law
we we we we would need some way to
enforce it but the idea would be if a
war were ever to break out instead the
first born children of both of both
countries world leaders have to fight to
the death
oh my and then the winner wins the war
spicy so you'd have like you know
putin's son would be like crazy ripped
and then zelinski's son or whatever and
if they don't have a son then they have
to fight they themselves i wonder if i'm
i'm kidding obviously with that idea but
i'm wondering if forcing the leaders to
put themselves on the line or their
families would be good for war yeah i
was just going to say that even if it's
not a dueling thing just in terms of if
there was a war yeah send them first
send the firstborn child see how you
know they would be like i would i would
not like to have this war yeah no they
would still do it and then the military
would ensure that their kid was never on
the front lines no no you know arena
duel like okay everyone shows up and
there's a big you know ring and they
bring the children of the world leaders
who want to who are going to war
and then uh
no here's what it would be the person
declaring war has to send their son and
if no son themselves and the uh person
being challenged can elect anyone they
want so here's what happens every world
leader adopts a kid they don't care
about him
i said first they never see that oh well
they could just adopt a kid before they
have any children i said first born or
themselves you'll be like i'm not gonna
have kids until after i declare my wars
that they then they personally haven't
they have to do it
and then the person who's who is the the
declare e the person who's getting to
war can choose anybody
so like putin would be like we're going
to war in ukraine and it's like all
right it's you were your son his
advantage and then zielenski would just
be like i'm going to find some great you
know mma dude and have him do it there
you go i have a feeling that that is how
it used to be and then they were like we
got to start telling them that we're
gods so they stopped making us go to war
with them we watched it treated with
royalty we watched troy this weekend you
guys ever see troy no no
and
it's like uh
achilles challenges the prince to a
battle i don't know basically like he
walks up to the gate by himself and
they're at war and he's like hector and
then they come out and they fight
one-on-one with all the soldiers
watching and it's kind of crazy to think
because
i can't imagine that if a u.s marine
walked up to like uh an al-qaeda base or
an isis base and yelled al baghdadi you
challenged me they would just be like
bang yeah
next like that was ridiculous what was
that all about but in these old stories
there was like honor and war and like
you would challenge someone to a fight
in fact in the movie the brother of
agamemnon i think it was
challenges paris the prince of troy to a
duel for his wife or whatever and it's
like all the armies are standing there
watching and i'm like this is ridiculous
did they really do that the stories say
that they did that they would send their
best warrior out and then the other side
would send their best warrior and it was
whoever won would basically decide the
battle so you'd have to throw a bunch of
people's lives away yeah maybe we should
still do that i think ballistics changed
everything there's that there's the art
of firing weapons the opening scene is
like
sparta is you know confronting this
other nation and they have this big
super ripped guy who's their champion
and achilles comes out and just runs up
and then like takes a sword one shots
him like in the neck and then he's like
ah and then then the leader of the enemy
you know the other side says like give
this scepter to a king for he rules our
country and like that's how it was i'm
like man that made things so much easier
i guess so i got you the boss now you
have become the president of this
country because you killed some dude a
guy who was like our guy and you beat
him it's pros and cons to that because
you could get a really strong dude that
whoops the other guy's butt but then
ends up being an absolute idiot so you
know yeah but now it's just whoever's
the best at gossiping yeah we're like
yes you win you can run the country now
you made him look bad and yourself look
good that's it it's kind of crazy how
things have gotten to this point
it is russia is absolutely terrible at
information war
so it's like
with all the censorship with all the
cutting off
it looks like what we're seeing with um
with china with india with mexico as
countries they're actually scared to get
involved and help rush out
because they it looks like they're like
nah russia's been canceled you know what
i mean
wow yeah isn't that interesting that an
entire country could be cancelled and
one of the things i was thinking about
was who do you think that a tesla
cutting off a tesla would affect most do
you think that would affect putin you
really think that would affect the
military would it affect olga who's
trying to take dimitri to the grocery
store and buy groceries for their family
like who do you really think is going to
affect i'm like do you want a civil war
in russia do you want them focus on
themselves yes i guess maybe that's an
approach but i but i think uh you know
what you end up seeing with this is just
the russian people genuinely hating the
rest of the world for doing it right
like why are you attacking me what did i
do putin was right right that's what
they're gonna say well we've we've
already seen those huge protests right
of russians who aren't interested in
going to war with ukraine like these are
the normal people who don't like what
putin is doing and we're punishing them
we're taking away all their
entertainment we're taking away their
ability to pay anything talk about
cutting off their teslas for pete's sake
thanks for checking out this segment
from the tim cast irl podcast but if you
want to check out the full show live
tune in monday through friday at 8 p.m
and if you want more special access
content head over to timcast.com and
become a member your membership helps
sustain this company keep our
journalists employed makes this show
happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
tim cast irl podcast and there's a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in monday through
friday at 8 pm we'll see you all there
you